Початок навчального року в Німеччині проходить
без урочистостих лінійок. Це свято лише для першачків -
для решти учнів звичайний день:
дітям роздають підручники, розклади
і вони обмінюються враженнями про канікули.
Практики задаровування вчителів квітами та цукерками
чи тим паче іншими подарунками тут немає.
"Потрібно здати у фонд школи, як минулого разу"
Розміри українських поборів у "фонд класу" чи "фонд школи"
чи "фонд школи" німців би шокували.
Так звана "каса класу" в Німеччині справді є.
Але оперує вона чисто символічними сумами:
батьки здають в середньому 10 євро на рік -
на ксерокопії або на поїздки дітей до музею.
Додатково можуть попросити здати гроші
на більш масштабні класні поїздки.
Але ціна таких поїздок формується максимально прозоро.
Сім'ям, які отримують соціальну допомогу
і не можуть самосітйно заплатити за поїздку,
допомагає фонд фінансової підтримки школи:
потрібно лише надати відповідне підтвердження.
Благодійні внески до такого фонду школи вітаються,
але вони зазвичай вельми скромні,
і це ніяк не впливає на ставлення до вашої дитини
та не поліпшить її успішність.
Оцінки – не найголовніше в німецькій школі.
Дітей вчать, насамперед, самостійно мислити, а не зубрити.
Значно важливіше, щоб ваша дитина навчилася поводити себе в соціумі,
проявляла індивідуальні здібності та росла толерантною.
Приміром, уже в початковій школі дітям пропонують спеціальні курси,
як уникати або запобігати конфліктам.
У деяких землях випробовують так звану інклюзивну модель -
тобто дітки з обмеженими можливостями
навчаються в тих же школах, що й решта,
що має сприяти їхній інтеграції в суспільство,
але разом з тим є величезним викликом для вчителів.
Оцінки стають по-справжньому важливими лише в старших класах,
коли йдеться про максимально добрий атестат,
який є пропускним квитком у виші.
А в перші роки навчання оцінки зазвичай не ставлять -
малечу заохочують смайликами або іншими веселими символами.
У початковій школі діти навчаються від 4 до 6 років -
залежно від федеральної землі.
Після цього дітей розподіляють у гімназії,
де потрібна добра успішність,
ґезамтшулє - загальні школи,
"реальні школи" для учнів із середніми результатами
і "гауптшулє", після якої зазвичай здобувають робітничі професії.
Середня освіта в Німеччині обов’язкова.
За пропусками уроків пильно стежать
вимагають записки від батьків або довідки від лікаря.
А їздити у відпустку зі школярами можна виключно під час канікул.
Про тримісячні літні канікули німецькі діти можуть тільки мріяти.
У ФРН вони тривають лише шість тижнів.
У які саме літні тижні будуть канікули,
кожна федеральна земля вирішує окремо
і з року в рік дата початку дитячого відпочинку різна.
Це роблять для того, щоб трохи розвантажити німецькі автобани і курорти.
Загалом освіта в Німеччині - це питання земельного рівня,
тому кожна федеральна земля визначає свої пріоритети.
Вважається, що найкраща шкілька освіта в Німеччині - у Баварії.